in North America sport is king let us
take you on a journey to visit some of
the most unique creatures on earth the
North American sports fans we begin in
Miami a Heat fan in all white he tries
to impress females by paying $40,000 for
courtside seats
but with LeBron Gordon and the team
returning true mediocrity he'll be
forced to spend his money on cocaine jet
ski parties here we see the recording
artist known is Drake watch his seamless
metamorphosis transforming his Raptors
Jersey in favor of the Miami Heat and
before you know it he's changed again to
Cleveland colors effortlessly aligning
with whomever is in the sport in Los
Angeles a self-proclaimed USC fan takes
a selfie the Trojans will most surely
lose this game but she is happy because
her face paint will look cute on
Instagram across the country in
Jacksonville
the elusive jaguars fan sleeps amidst
empty seats every year these sparse fans
face the threat of the franchise
migrating making them the most
endangered fanbase in North America here
we see a Broncos fan hi has balls
this man is excited about the team's
chances ah it appears he's gotten too
high drifting into thoughts about how
sports don't really matter the players
don't care about him what's the point he
thinks the teams are just giant
corporations mmm
these cheese balls sure are good though
they're like little Broncos players this
one would be Monta cheese boar Monta
cheese more tis young and finally the
Pittsburgh Pirates farm 160 drew games
500 hours of his life goal in an instant
because the Pirates didn't show up on
the one day it counted it's too much for
this poor creature to process and so he
waits seeking closure that will never
come
well until next time I'm sport gaming
ttan and a hope you've enjoyed your fan
Safari
you